كولومبيا أرض النكهة الملونة ولكن إذا
كنت تعرف عن الثمار الغنية وغير العادية بشكل لا يصدق التي
يجب أن يقدمها هذا البلد
بفضل تنوعه البيولوجي ، فإن الأرض
تنتج أشهى الأطباق مثل
غوانابانا الذي يشبه عصور ما قبل التاريخ
وبخار ماجو الغامض والذي يجلبنا إلى
هنا ، فهذا ليس لك  قسم إنتاج البقالة النموذجي ،
هذا هو فم بالاكاي مرحبًا بك في بوجوت كسوق مثالي
، هذا هو
المكان المناسب للعثور على
الفواكه ذات النكهة الأكثر غموضًا عبر
الوضع الشاذ للحنك ماريو كاريو
ماريكو في عازف الفلوت الميت تانغو
ميتامورس eileen.tan هل تريد أن
تفترض  furutaka Zeb para Prepararse para المفضلين
لدينا مضيفة الآنسة Runa put'em ،
نحن maracas muchos casitas حسنًا ، إنهم
مرتاحون للغرب أبدًا لم يعجبني أبدًا
عصر cuando yo pequeña الخارجي.
تمشي بسرعة في دائرة ،
حسنًا نافذتي هناك لأن este es
فيلموجرافيا لا
[موسيقى]
hakuna fruta ca  قم بطبيب طبي إيباكا ليما
نعم مستشفى ترى آشا عندما تكون
الروح المعنوية طريقة كامالا متساوية مع بلانكا ،
مرحبًا آلان نعم ، ترى أن هذا هو الجزء العلوي من
تي تي تي تي الآن يقول أنك على لافتة تسلسلية
هذه هي أغنيتك ثم تشعر بذلك عندما
يكونون هناك  بروتامين hombres
Alex وهو يدعم عدم ظهور أوما
مانجو عيد الفصح أكبر نقول نحن ريك
ديليسيوسو من الاسم حتى نعرف
الله أن نفعل حق النقض DNA المثير للاشمئزاز من a
de la cosa Paulo kamau هو مكان خاص
ينفجر به  يقدم اللون والنكهة
للعالم مجموعة لا يمكن الاستغناء عنها
من الهدايا الرحيق بالطبع
طالما كانوا في المقعد